je viens en principe ne peux t'empêcher
ducey bouchard de devenir chef du parti
québécois et premier ministre du québec
à minuit ce soir il sera l'unique
candidat à la succession de monsieur
jacques parizeau et a décidé de me
prendre par la tête
jean chrétien dit on a réagi comme toute
autre personne à sa place il s'est cru
agressé et s'est défendu
robert bourassa laisse derrière lui un
héritage à la fois riche et un bide et
unitaires ont commencé à arriver
les 260 mm de pluie en 24 heures ce
n'est pas le déluge mais précise ce
qu'on peut encore faire c'est de se
préparer pour le pire c'est ce que les
autorités sont en train de faire le
clonage d'un animal adultes qui était
jusqu'à présent considéré comme
impossible en raison de la complexité
d'un corps adulte
le forum c'est le temple c'est la mecque
du rock qui seront nombreux les vétérans
i les légendes à venir y faire leurs
adieux une atmosphère extraordinaire qui
règne ici
le centre non semaine et vive le centre
mons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]